[Music]
hello there welcome back I'm glad you
could join me today let's just dive
right in and run all the colors across
the screen that you'll need to paint
along with me I have my regular old
canvas here wet and ready to go now
let's grab our trusty two-inch brush
here whack that off a little bit just be
like it owes you money we're gonna get a
little damp or yellow snow here mix that
with just another little dab of our
Betty White
now well that's just Daniel Sedin happy
little sky
remember this is your world you get to
make and break the rules here sweet baby
Jesus wish I could jump in there and
roll around and all that cascading white
powder yeah just get high and all of
life's splendor God I love cocaine so
much holy [ __ ] knuckles I am high as a
kite right now okay let's paint in a few
little happy trees there nothing wrong
with making friends with trees you know
what you don't want to do is eat these
paints trust me on this one all right
I'm gonna walk off from Ken that's right
that feels good
[Laughter]
would you look at that it seems like we
have ourselves a finished painting so
from our family to yours keep your pants
dry your dreams went and remember hugs
death drugs
[Music]